we watch
we listen
and we remember the past is already
written
the ink is dry
they have no idea what's going to happen
hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones West world
crossover video George R Martin was
calling for it and there was a big twist
during the west-world finale so this is
gonna be an explanation for how that
would work and what would go down if you
haven't been watching Westworld there's
the idea that it is a theme park a very
big theme park but just like Disneyland
has a Star Wars land then it has other
parks like Epcot Center West world on
the TV show has multiple parks West
world is just the name of one of the
parks so Game of Thrones land like
medieval world in the original West
world movie would just be a separate
Park for just a quick reminder there is
new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so that you don't miss out
on anything during the offseason so
there are a couple of complications to
doing a game of Thrones West world
crossover because West world is a story
all about hosts achieving consciousness
the robots become self-aware then they
rebel so there are really two types of
stories that you could do with the Game
of Thrones West world crossover one it
could be a story about how all these
characters in season eight after they
finally defeat the White Walkers and end
the threat of a second long night wake
up to the fact that they're really
robots on a loop break it and then break
out of the park so when we think about
the world of Game of Thrones planet os--
is kind of like the unofficial name for
it you'd have to localize it to a
certain part of the world of Game of
Thrones so it'd have to like just take
place in Westeros the only real way
around that to do like an entirely
self-contained Game of Thrones West
world type story would be to have it set
on Mars there was a lot of theories
during West world this season that it
might be set on Mars because the park
itself is so big but that is just one of
the questions that they haven't answered
on West world yet so the other big
problem you know number two is that how
you would address the changing time
periods on Game of Thrones because the
Song of Ice and Fire is this big saga
that goes all the way back thousands of
years into the history of the world of
Planet os-- so the way they deal with
this on West world is the
they change people's narratives all the
time the hosts have like a set loop that
they're on they have certain responses
that they're programmed to give people
based on input that they get like if you
walk up and say hello they're programmed
to greet you if you do something that
tries to throw them off their loop they
have some defense mechanisms built into
their programming that keeps them from
glitching out
now obviously the west-world TV shows
all about them breaking that loop but if
we're gonna do Game of Thrones and we
have like Daenerys we have Jon Snow
hosts let's assume they don't break
their loop so if you walked up to Jon
Snow and tried to tell him that he's the
son of Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen at the beginning of his loop
he might not believe you like he would
just be like that doesn't make any sense
you would have to take him along the
full loop to show him the evidence to
see the story play out but what you
could do if you wanted to see Robert's
rebellion is that the people that were
running the game of Thrones park-like
the West world people you have to
imagine that they're running a game of
Thrones Park by itself that's separate
from the West world Park is that they
could change all the hosts narratives
use the same hosts like use the Daenerys
the Jon Snow host and just make them
their ancestors so you could do
historical story lines like Aegon's
conquest of the Seven Kingdoms
but Daenerys would have to be written as
one of a Gahan sister wives so like she
would look like Daenerys but she would
be thinking and acting like one of the
sister wives
so the West world Park always has like
an entry point that it brings all the
guests the further you travel out from
that kind of home based place the
crazier the story gets the more
dangerous it gets
so what you would have to do is you
would have to bring all the guests into
King's Landing
that would be like the place where
they're really safe really based stories
where people could go to the whorehouse
but the people that wanted a more
dangerous story could travel to the
frozen north the edge of the park would
be like the lands of always winter so
you could actually do white Walker stuff
but it would be like at the very edge of
the park so the other problem too is
that Daenerys doesn't get her dragons
told much much later in the story so
everyone would want to be able to ride a
dragon that'd be a lot of fun to write a
dragon host but well you'd have to do is
you'd have to compress the Game of
Thrones story so imagine Game of Thrones
one when Ned Stark brings his family to
King's Landing you have all those
characters all near the same place you'd
have to bring Daenerys to say like
Dragonstone at that same time when
really at that point in the story she
hasn't hatched her dragons yet she still
hasn't got married to Khal Drogo so
you'd have to shoehorn in a lot of plot
to a relatively small amount of time
just to make it all work together but
that way you could have Daenerys strafe
King's Landing every once in a while but
for the most part the hosts are designed
to be on a one day loop so you really
only get as much as you can do in one
day of story which means that you'd have
to be really picky about the one day
that you do like you could do the day of
Blackwater so that Stannis attacks
Tyrion unleashes the Wildfire like
there's this big battle you have to
defend the red keep but elsewhere up in
the Riverlands you'd have to do war of
the five kings stuff if you were to
travel to Harrenhal you could do tourney
of Harrenhal with Rhaegar Targaryen
Lyanna stark knight of the Laughing tree
but it would really require you to
compress all those events that in the
story of A Song of Ice and Fire are
happening during very different time
periods but in the park that is Game of
Thrones land inside West world it would
all be happening at the same time it's
just that geographically they would be
very far apart so that they wouldn't
overlap that much but travel in West
world is done via train so they'd have
to find a way around that in Game of
Thrones land like horses only move so
fast so people always joke about little
fingers mass rapid transit system like
he gets all the way from the Vale up to
the north super quickly Varys is able to
travel very quickly so the only way to
travel
extremely fast would be on dragon bag so
that would also require some shoehorning
because there are only three dragons and
they'd have to start their loop at one
specific place like a dragon stone but
you guys can let me know how would you
want them to do a game of Thrones land
inside the world of West world they
would definitely have to make the world
smaller and if they did it as a direct
crossover like if at the end of West
world they just go into a different room
and you see like a Daenerys looking host
and you're like oh my god there is a
Game of Thrones land you would have to
be a setup like
the samurai world on West world where
they're just testing it out they haven't
opened it to the public yet so you'd
have to imagine that a lot of the Game
of Thrones story that we've seen is just
the host like it would be the West world
people just testing out that part before
they open it to the public because then
you get like all the regular people
coming in trying to throw hosts off
their loop like people trying to get
help from Ned Stark you know pull him
off his loop maybe he doesn't get
beheaded but there's always some big
twist someone with a secret agenda at
the top like the Delos corporation the
people that actually own the park then
you have the Robert Ford character that
has his own agenda who's trying to free
the hosts allow them to attain
consciousness so you'd have to find a
way to write in george RR martin himself
to the story where he's trying to free
all of these Game of Thrones hosts so in
the game of thrones land scenario george
RR martin is the robert ford character
being pushed out by the del o's
corporation which would be like the HBO
executives in this case because the fun
thing about the west-world TV show is
that it's also kind of a metaphor about
making television like you try to make
this narrative but you have all these
executive external forces trying to make
money off the show while you the creator
or just trying to tell this amazing
story so that's why you have to
appreciate HBO in real life with this
West world TV show because they're so
cool with being satirized in that way I
think they don't mind as long as it's
really good television
like they really just want a hit show
that everybody wants to see
but let's fan cast it so Dolores would
probably be the Daenerys character
meaning that Teddy would be Jon Snow and
obviously I think that the man in black
would have to be Littlefinger the person
who feels like the world belongs to him
but isn't destined to be there seems
like he wants to help everyone when
really he just wants it for himself let
me know in the comments though how crazy
would you go if they made a real-life
Game of Thrones theme part we're a long
ways away from that level of technology
but obviously I'll be doing Westworld
Game of Thrones bonus videos in the off
season Game of Thrones even though it's
taking a long time to get here we'll get
here a lot faster than Westworld season
- but congratulations to this week's
Game of Thrones giveaway winner ink
panther you win a $20 Amazon gift card
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there is a new round
that started now so I'll just remind
people when I post my next Westworld in
Game of Thrones videos but there's all
kinds of midseason finales happening
tonight so my next video will be the
flash midseason finale while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my West world finale video with a
little bit about season 2 and you can
click here for my breakdown of that Game
of Thrones teaser they just drop thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight